foreign
[Music]
obviously the military drills they are
not unexpected because the Chinese have
never ruled out the possibility of
unifying Taiwan with the mainland
through the use of force I think it is
about Beijing one thing to Signal its
ongoing resolve to oppose Taiwanese
activities that have the potential to
undercut its authority over Taipei
[Music]
much of the tensions actually involve
domestic public opinion you've got
elections coming up in Taiwan you've got
elections coming up in in the United
States and Chinese don't have elections
but they certainly have a lot of
domestic constituents to be concerned
about